nami merci chers collègues donc la
parole à bruno belin nouveaux collègues
depuis 2020 de la délégation malama miss
merci de votre écoute et votre
disponibilité
pour nous ce matin moi j'en viens au
sujet la violence c'est une réalité
dramatique à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés je pense tous donnent
responsabilité d'élus locaux et la
situation de la ruralité créer une vraie
fracture de solutions dans ces
situations là il n'y a pas de moyens de
mobilité
il n'ya pas donc il n'ya pas de dubert
ya pas de taxes il n'y a pas de ligne de
bus il ya pas de ya rien de disponible à
2 heures du matin à part trouvé
le maire
qui fait office et on n'a pas de
solution de logement alors déjà moi ça
m'a toujours choqué que c'est la victime
qui doivent parfois en pleine nuit être
déplacée et non pas l'auteur des faits
en employant du conditionnel s'il le
faut et on n'a pas de solution de
logement donc il faut un moment donné
qu'on se pose avec les bailleurs sociaux
dont c'est la responsabilité en milieu
rural d'avoir des contingents le terme
est pas sans doute celui qu'il faut mais
on comprend tout ce que ça veut dire
c'est à dire que là où il ya des
réalisation d'opérations de logements
sociaux qu'il y ait partout de la
disponibilité fléché à ces situations là
qui existe partout on va pas le nier
parce que aussi déplacé ces familles là
c'est bien souvent s'y déplacer enfin
dépassé pendant ces femmes-là s'est
déplacé les enfants et donc on les sort
du collège ou de l'école du coin du
village et donc s'il ya encore une
pénalité pour eux et puis l'autre
réalité aussi des bailleurs sociaux
moi je rejoins ma collègue qui est
intervenu en premier les familles
monoparentales le cette initiation qui
va s'inscrire dans le temps
c'est une évidence or aujourd'hui on
voit bien que dans les commissions
d'attribution des logements sociaux
quand on a ce type de situations à
défendre les critères ne permettent pas
l'attribution logements sociaux donc là
où elles devraient où elle voudrait
quitter un logement dans lesquelles sont
exposés pour des questions de violence
établi
il faut absolument qu'on mette les
bailleurs sociaux dans la boucle et avec
des obligations de présence en milieu
rural la ruralité c'est 15 millions de
français qui y vivent et donc il va
falloir qu'on mette systématiquement je
pense dans les lois des dispositions
diverses dans les situations de ruralité
voit la première intervention j'aurai
besoin mais ça sera un autre sujet aussi
parce que la situation de l'allongement
denis vg va faire débat avec certains de
nos collègues j'en suis certain il
faudra qu'on ait des des arguments débit
comme on dit voilà je suis prêt à
défendre en tant que professionnels de
santé c'est un sujet sur lequel je crois
qu'il faut absolument aussi défendre
mais je peux vous assurer qu'il va
falloir qu'on est même xd des arguments
avec un certain nombre de nos collègues
même si on les aime beaucoup